>> I GUESS I SHOULD BE FLATTERED
PEOPLE ARE COMING BECAUSE I’M
THE NICE GUY.
THAT’S THE REASON WHY IT’S
HAPPENING, THAT I’M A DECENT
MAN, HOW I WAS RAISED.
THAT’S WHY THEY ARE COMING
BECAUSE BIDEN IS A GOOD GUY.
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS NOTHING
HAS CHANGED.
AS MANY PEOPLE CAME --
MARIA: THAT WAS PRESIDENT JOE
BIDEN TELLING AMERICA THAT THE
SITUATION AT THE BORDER HAS NOT
CHANGED BUT THE NUMBERS TELL A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT STORY AND
WE HAVE THOSE NUMBERS HERE.
THIS CHART SHOWS THE SPIKE FROM
JUST ONE YEAR AGO.
AND AS YOU CAN SEE, IT IS
SPIKING.
SENATOR TED CRUZ TOLD US ON THIS
PROGRAM LAST WEEK HE BELIEVES
THIS IS A DIRECT CONSEQUENCE OF
3 CRITICAL DECISIONS THAT JOE
BIDEN MADE DURING HIS FIRST WEEK
AS PRESIDENT.
WATCH.
SENATOR: NUMBER 1, HE
IMMEDIATELY HALTED CONSTRUCTION
OF THE BORDER WALL AND WE SAW
SECTIONS TO HAVE BORDER WALL
WHERE LITERALLY THEY ARE HALF
DONE AND THERE’S RUSTED REBAR
EVERYWHERE.
THEY JUST LEFT IT.
THEY JUST LEFT IT WITH HOLES IN
IT AND, OF COURSE, ILLEGAL
TRAFFIC IS STREAMING THROUGH
THOSE HOLES.
NUMBER 2, JOE BIDEN REINSTATED
THE FAILED CATCH AND RELEASE
POLICY.
IN OTHER WORDS, WHEN SOMEONE IS
CAUGHT, THEY END UP BEING GIVEN
A COURT DATE SOME TIME IN THE
FUTURE, RELEASED AND EVERYONE
KNOWS A VERY SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
THEM EVER SHOW UP AGAIN.
AND NUMBER 3, THIS IS PROBABLY
THE MOST INEXPLICABLE, BIDEN
ENDED THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
AGREEMENT.
MARIA: AND JOINING ME NOW IS
FORMER ACTING DHS SECRETARY CHAD
WOLF WHO ONE INSTRUMENTAL IN
IMPLEMENTING PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
BORDER POLICIES AND HE’S WITH US
NOW.
SECRETARY, PLEASURE TO SEE YOU.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
DO YOU AGREE WITH WHAT YOU JUST
HEARD FROM TED CRUZ AS THE 3
MOST IMPORTANT THINGS THAT BIDEN
DID TO OVERTURN TRUMP POLICIES
AND, IN FACT, IN DOING SO CAUSED
THIS SURGE AT THE BORDER?
CHAD: WELL, THE SENATOR IS
CERTAINLY RIGHT.
THE THREE MEASURES IMPACTED THE
SURGE THAT WE SEE AND I WOULD
ADD ONTO THAT, THE FACT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT ENFORCING
A TITLE 42 CDC PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDER ON MINORS IS CONTRIBUTING
DIRECTLY TO THE SURGE THAT WE
SEE IN MINORS TODAY.
OVER 5, 6,000 IN CBP COST DYE
AND--CUSTODY BECAUSE OF SPECIFIC
MEASURE NOT TO EMPLOY THE PUBLIC
HEALTH ORDER FOR MINORS.
REMEMBER THIS, MARIA, THEY ARE
USING THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
AUTHORITY TO TURN AROUND SINGLE
ADULTS AND SOME FAMILIES WHO
HAVE MINORS AND THEY ARE TURNING
MINORS BACK TO MEXICO BUT THEY
WILL NOT TURN MINORSES TO
NORTHERN TRIANGLE AND PUT THEM
ON FAMILIES WHICH IS WHAT WE DID
DURING THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS HAVING A SIGNIFICANT
EFFECT ON THE SURGE THAT WE SEE
WITH MINORS AND CERTAINLY THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM OR MPP
IS CONTRIBUTING TO THE SURGE
WITH FAMILY UNITS AND THE CATCH
AND RELEASE THAT THE SENATOR
TALKED ABOUT.
MARIA: YEAH, IT’S SO IMPORTANT
TO GO THROUGH THIS -- AND, YOU
KNOW, WE KNOW THAT JOE BIDEN
CARVED OUT AN EXCEPTION FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE MINORS.
FAMILY WITH A 6-YEAR-OLD OR
YOUNGER.
JUST LIKE THAT, WE SUDDENLY SEE
FAMILIES WITH 6-YEAR-OLDS OR
YOUNGER, BUT THEY ARE RENTING
THE KIDS, RIGHT, IT’S NOT EVEN
THEIR KIDS, THEY ARE TRYING TO
HAVE THE COOKIE-CUTTER THAT JOE
BIDEN SAID WILL LET IN.
CHAD: WHAT WE KNOW THE SMUGGLERS
ARE SOPHISTICATED AND THEY KNOW
OUR POLICIES AND PROCEDURES, SO
WHEN THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
START TO CARVE OUT DIFFERENT
POPULATIONS AND GROUPS OF
INDIVIDUALS, THOSE ARE EXACTLY
AS YOU INDICATED, THOSE ARE THE
GROUPS OF INDIVIDUALS WE START
SEEING AT THE BORDER BECAUSE
THAT’S WHO THEY GO AND RECRUIT.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY, THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW IS NOT
ENFORCING OR NOT -- THERE IS NO
IMMIGRATION CONSEQUENCE TO
ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR.
THEY ARE SIMPLY TREATING THIS AS
A CAPACITY ISSUE.
SO THEY ARE BUILDING MORE
FACILITIES, THEY ARE TRYING TO
PROCESS MORE INDIVIDUALS THROUGH
AND THEY ARE NOT HOLDING
INDIVIDUALS ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT
ILLEGAL BEHAVIOR AND THAT’S WHAT
YOU HAVE TO DO AT THE END OF THE
DAY TO STOP THE CRISIS AND THE
SURGE THAT WE SEE ON THE BORDER.
SO THERE’S GOING TO BE A NUMBER
OF POLICIES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
NEED TO BE CHANGED AND ENFORCED
IF WE WANT TO SEE AN END TO
THIS.
MARIA: WHAT ARE THE BORDER
AGENTS TELLING YOU ON THE
GROUND?
ONE OF MY SOURCES ON THE BORDER
TOLD ME THAT THEY’LL BE 5,000
AGENTS RETIRING AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT GOING TO
REPLACE THEM.
IT SEEMS LIKE OUR OFFICIALS ON
THE GROUND, THOSE PEOPLE ON THE
FRONT LINES, BORDER CUSTOMS
PATROL ARE DEALING WITH THIS
WITH THEIR HANDS TIED BEHIND
THEIR BACK.
ALSO CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL
CHIEF HASTINGS TWEETED THIS THAT
RIO GRANDE VALLEY AGENTS COUNTED
860 CRIMINAL ALIENS, 92 SEX
OFFENDERS, 64 MEMBERS OF VIOLENT
GANGS, SO THEY ARE DEALING WITH
THIS ON THE GROUND.
REPRESENTATIVE HENRY CUELLAR
FROM TEXAS SAID THOUSANDS ARE
BEING RELEASED INTO TEXAS ON THE
HONOR SYSTEM WITHOUT COURT
INFORMATION OR NOTICES TO
APPEAR.
SO YOU’VE GOT SOME -- SOME
REALLY TOUGH, YOU KNOW, DEALINGS
THAT OUR BORDER AGENTS HAVE TO
FACE OFF MEANWHILE, YOU HAVE
5,000 OF THEM ABOUT TO RETIRE.
CHAD: YEAH, IT’S ABSOLUTELY
FRUSTRATING FOR BORDER PATROL
AGENTS TODAY AND I TALKED TO
SEVERAL OF THEM.
THOSE IN THE RIO GRANDE VALLEY,
RGV, GROUND ZERO WHERE A LOT OF
THE SURGE IS OCCURRING, ALMOST
HALF, HALF OF THEM ARE NO LONGER
ON THE BORDER DOING THE NATIONAL
SECURITY MISSION.
THEY ARE BACK AT BORDER PATROL
STATIONS CARRYING AND FEEDING
FOR THESE THOUSANDS OF
INDIVIDUALS IN THEIR FACILITIES.
THAT’S NOT WHAT THEY SIGNED UP
FOR.
THAT’S NOT THEIR TRAINING.
THEIR TRAINING IS TO ENFORCE THE
LAW, MAKING SURE THAT DRUGS AND
CONTRABAND AND OTHER ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS ARE NOT COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
OVER HALF OF THEM IN RGV ARE NOT
DOING THAT TODAY.
THAT’S WHY YOU SEE PERHAPS
INCREASE IN NUMBER OF CRIMINALS
AND OTHERS BECAUSE CARTELS WILL
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THAT.
AT THE END TO HAVE DAY, ALSO OUR
BORDER PATROL AGENTS WILL LISTEN
TO TV AND LISTEN TO TELEVISION
AND SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT ARE
COMING FROM DHS LEADERSHIP AS
WELL AS THE WHITE HOUSE AND SO
WHEN THEY HEAR THAT LEADERSHIP
SAYING THE BORDER IS CLOSED, THE
BORDER IS SECURE, THEY KNOW
THAT’S A LIE.
THEY KNOW THAT’S A LIE AND I
BELIEVE THERE’S A LOSS OF
CONFIDENCE IN BOTH DEPARTMENTAL
LEADERSHIP AS WELL AS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE WITH YOUR AGENTS
A@BORDER PATROL.
MARIA: YEAH, THAT HAS MASSIVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
REAL QUICK, WHO DO YOU THINK IS
IN CHARGE?
JOE BIDEN SAID KAMALA HARRIS IS
IN CHARGE.
SHE SAID, NO, NO, I’M NOT TAKING
THAT ON.
I’M JUST DOING DIPLOMACY.
CHAD: WELL, IT’S VERY CONFUSING.
YOU HAVE DHS SECRETARY.
YOU HAVE A SOUTHERN BORDER
COORDINATOR OUT OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
YOU HAVE A VICE PRESIDENT AND
YOU HAVE ENVOY, ENVOY FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
IT’S ALL VERY CONFUSING AND WHAT
THIS TELLS YOU IS THAT THERE’S A
LOT OF HIGH-LEVEL INDIVIDUALS
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION FOCUSED
ON THIS BECAUSE OF THE CRISIS,
BECAUSE OF THE HISTORIC NATURE
OF THE BORDER.
MARIA: WE WILL SEE IF THIS WILL
CHANGE AND TAKE A MIA CULPA AND
REINSTATE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
YOUR GUIDELINES POLICIES THAT